eigentlich ist chemie ganz ein lieber
aber wenn jimmy einen anderen hund sid
ist er kaum noch zu bändigen und leiden
zwar die chance genau zu tun was
frauchen w
denkste und wieder ein anderer
verwechselt kamera mit leckerli hunde
sind eben nur die besten freunde des
menschen wenn der mensch den hund
trainiert und das geht alleine nicht
geht auch nicht über internet oder
irgendwelche fernsehsendung ich brauche
trainer hier bezugsperson für den multi
hundetrainer haben konjunktur
herrchen und frauchen suchen sich
professionelle hilfe für ihre tiere weil
ich so viele hunde see auf der straße
die also überhaupt nicht sozialisiert
sind die also sich auf meinen hund
stützen obwohl meiner überhaupt nichts
getan hat und da bin ich also schon der
meinung dass das jeder hund und jeder
hundehalter vernünftig auch mit dem hund
umgeht ich meine man fährt ja auch nicht
auto wenn man nicht auto fahren kann man
braucht eben einen führerschein
der sogenannte hundeführerschein ist in
teilen deutschlands pflicht dort müssen
die halter mit ihren hunden eine prüfung
machen immer öfter bereiten 100 trainer
hund und herrchen darauf vor
die politik will dass sie in zukunft dem
trainer titel durch eine staatliche
prüfung erwärmen
in theorie und praxis die derzeitigen
trainer fühlen sich
die masse an hundetrainern hat sich in
den letzten jahren qualifizierten
ausbildungen unterzogen und die
problematik im moment ist einfach dass
genau diese ausbildungsabschluss eben
nicht anerkannt werden und somit dem
viel frohsinn basis entsteht weil die
leute sagen ich habe viel geld
ausgegeben ich habe keine förderung
bekommen
ich habe tausende von euro meine
ausbildung investiert und dies jetzt
nichts wert kai völker ist so ein fall
für seine kunden ist er der
hundeflüsterer ein mann der schon viele
probleme hunde zum gehorsam erzogen hat
er kritisiert den staatlichen test als
zu theoretisch
das ist so ein multiple choice test der
per computer gemacht wird der werden
teilweise auch fachfragen aus dem thema
die zynischen bereich gestellt mit denen
hundetrainer eigentlich überhaupt nichts
zu tun hat
weil wenn ich als trainer feststelle
dass der hohen krankheits problem hat
schenkt ihm zum tierarzt
da frage ich mich warum das veterinäramt
nicht einfach sagt wir kommen schauen
uns dein training an
und entscheidend auf grund der tatsache
wie du mit den hunden umgehen
doch die politik verteidigt den test
hier geht es in erster linie darum dass
jeder hundetrainer eine ausbildung nach
gleichen richtlinien absolviert hat ja
das ist ganz wichtig damit nicht
irgendwelche wildwuchs da als ob jeder
ausleben kann was er möchte und in der
richtung ist das natürlich auch mit
unseren europäischen gesetzen
man kann es toll finden dass in jedem
land das anders ist aber wenn wir
gemeinsam was haben dann sollten
zumindest jetzt in europa der in unserem
fall in deutschland
die standards für runde mit ihnen umgeht
identisch sein
hundetrainer und besitzer sind skeptisch
ob die politischen vorgaben mensch und
tier weiter bringe eine hundeschule ohne
staatliche zertifikate sei immer noch
besser als gar keine hundeschule
ich habe tatsächlich das gefühl es gibt
eine super ruhe grauzone menschen mit
unerzogenen hunden die dann aber das
haus nicht verlassen oder nur nachts
oder sogar die erziehung des hundes ist
eben eine ernste angelegenheit
selten ist es amüsant wenn hunde nicht
parieren
so wie hier vor wie effekt
also sie kommt es dauert